welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by simon
brown who is the founder of digital 51
digital 51 are a startup consultancy
specializing within product design and
development
simon has worked within the industry
since 2014 at 2004.
within that time he's worked for
multiple brands from reed morgan hunt
cooper lomas and digital gurus he has
always managed to progress his
recruitment career within these brands
and in his last three positions before
he started digital 51 he was in a direct
position and sat on the board
however in march 2021
simon was time to to go on his own
recruitment entrepreneurial journey so
he launched digital 51 with his
co-founders
with one clear mission which i think is
really unique and great about this when
i spoke to simon so that clear mission
is for the business to be employee owned
and for simon to give away the business
in its 11th year to all of the people
that have helped it become a success so
that's by 2032.
there's no small print there's no
catches you can see on their website
simon is committed to to making this
happen so right now they're in their
first year of business they kind of have
six people in the company um someone was
just telling me that they're very close
to hitting their first year target
they're eight months in so uh yeah have
had a good start and have big plans for
2022. so simon welcome to the pod
thank you
awesome now i'm really looking forward
to this so there's loads that we can go
into
and there's a few things that we're
going to focus on but where i always
like to start as a million-pound
question
and that is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant of
today what does that look like for you
it's so funny that how it for me it's
it's it's changed yeah over over the
time and um obviously listening to the
pod i had a feeling obviously you'd kick
off here
and do you know right now um
if i could have anything i'd have i'd
have curious people
i'd have a curious mind in
because i think that historically had to
hit you with uh you know drive
determination resilience
but i think that
it's i think it's gone past that for me
in terms of i think you really need to
have
that curiosity of what's happening
within
business what's happening within people
what's happening within the wider
economy
digitally for us
and therefore like top thing right now
is curious the other reason is most
people aren't looking for that so
therefore if you look for that you you
find people who stand out so people are
people who are curious in that way
i think
that
you you definitely have to
you have to have a passion
and
you have to have
a passion for
what what you're doing and why you're
doing it and your reason can become your
reason can be completely different and
it should be that you know if you're
starting out your reasons should be
different to me at this point in my
career
and i shouldn't i shouldn't be trying to
put mine on you but i think you've got a
passion for what what that reason is so
on you know
a cold wednesday night away at stoke you
can get up for it and you can really get
it done which in recruitment is you know
the day after maybe
a deal that's not going your way or
the monday after a week before when
things just haven't panned out and it's
that that that passion
is in my opinion most important to keep
you going yeah so for me curiosity
passion
we teach you the rest yeah i love that
so
obviously been in recruitment for some
time
right so there's obviously loads that we
could unpack here right but as we were
just saying where i really want to focus
on is
yeah just talk a bit about why simon has
always managed to progress because most
people listen to this will have
aspirations to
achieve promotions achieve top bill of
status wherever it may be maybe start
their own company um so we're going to
talk a bit about that but also uh really
sort of um keen to dig into uh the mbo
journey that you experienced which
didn't obviously quite happen so we're
going to talk a bit about that because i
know
there's let me just meet myself
sorry about that yeah i always forget
that there's a fire alarm on fridays but
yeah as i was saying do you live in
student digs
i just do it every single friday in the
office it's [ __ ] the night
so um no what i was saying was yeah i
want to talk about the mbo piece just
because i'm speaking to a lot of young
aspirational leaders in companies right
now and that really seems to be the most
common carrot that they're getting is
like simon you're an associate director
you're a director and we want to sell
the company or we want to achieve this
so yeah keen to figure that into a
review and then we'll then really talk
about
yeah last last eight months or so this
51 you obviously finally took your own
took the lead to start your own business
and we'll talk a bit about what that's
been like in yeah the climate that we're
we're all operating in or have been in
the last 18 months so that's what we're
going to work through all right so let's
let's start with then
like talk when i say when i say to you
like why was simon brown able to
get the promotions get the director
position get at the board seat like why
was you able to i know obviously it was
from reedy that managed to to sort of
achieve that
why was you able to get those because as
we know right recruitment is competitive
externally but it's also bloody
competitive internally so why why do you
think what comes to mind when i say why
do you think he was able to get those
promotion opportunities maybe over the
people sitting next to you that were
trying to go for those as well
i think and you know what first of all
it's a bit of an out-of-body experience
to hear someone else talk about your
journey and then and sort of reflect it
positively because i don't think we do
enough of that um
yeah and and yeah so
and i think at the time you're on the
journey
you don't you're not always thinking
about it you're just you just do it and
you're in goal mode and you're just
moving forward yeah
it is competitive it is busy and you
know
therefore you don't think about it till
afterwards but
for me i made a conscious decision to go
to
to go to morgan hunt i i did just under
five years at reed and it was it was
brilliant it was the best place for me
to start i start i started in the
liverpool branch on the desk park
qualified accountancy
with
a sort of team of six or seven who were
just experienced around me and
that they sort of beasted me and got me
moving and plus the training was
phenomenal and being really honest and
it was just they set you up in the right
way however it took me on a bit of a
journey around
all things business development i wasn't
on a desk for that long you know i was
only 12 months and then i actually
applied for an internal um promotion
because one of the reasons i chose read
was they had this national account
portfolio yeah i wanted to test that and
say right well you know does that exist
and and i and i did apply for it and i
was i was lucky and i got i got my first
national account manager's job after
well within my first 15 16 months that
gave me a real flavor for for pure bd
not not job-based bd but contract-based
bd in terms of winning bigger contracts
pitches tenders presentations
national agreements
and
that that took me on a journey
and that journey
took me to a point where
as much as i loved working at reed and i
loved what i built there i wanted to be
in a more entrepreneurial environment
because it because it wasn't it was a
machine it was a machine it worked and
it worked at a very high end but
i wanted to work slightly differently at
times and and that sort of obviously
that's not how that's not how certain
machines work so
i think the reason
i was able to get just first of all on
the path was i made the conscious
decision i i chose to leave something
that was good and to be honest i've
always done that i've always left
wanting more i've always left each
position where's that where's that come
from
well i think you've got back yourself
first of all in terms of i quit
read i quit morgan hunt makes me sad
this makes me not sound like a quitter
uh both of them happened around four
times
four and a half years and five years i'm
itching i'm out
but it's a cycle for me it's a cycle
i've always said this you know
recruitment is monotonous it is the same
thing over and over again and therefore
you need to be stimulated and and you
need to be in that environment so
i
i quit what i was saying is i quit those
things um
and cooper lawman to be honest all three
of them with nothing to go to um
yeah i backed myself when i was at reed
i i was a very good national business
development manager winning
sort of multi-million pound contracts
across managed service and and i had a
sort of decent name and brand and
and i thought um i'll i'll get something
i also i still lived in liverpool but i
covered nationally and i was like ready
to move to london and sort of see if the
page that you know the streets were
really paid for gold
so
so i went to an environment at morgan
hunt which for the first six months i
personally found really difficult you
know that business was entrepreneurial
to its core
um
it had a the most boisterous the most
brilliant sales floor in london it had
two brilliant regional offices in
manchester and birmingham
and it was high performing individuals
and for the first six months i didn't
really enjoy it because it was so
it was so sort of entrepreneurial there
wasn't a structure and that's what i was
used to i was used to that yeah
and i remember sitting down with the
director who had sort of followed that
and my pitch to them had been let me
call let me come
that like a brilliant business
development function but it was really a
bid function and i wanted to make it
more client services more
um proactive selling yeah and
after six months i just wasn't sure i
sat down with director and i said to her
you know
just don't think this is for me i don't
think i'm enjoying it here i don't think
you know i don't think it needs someone
like me and and she said to me we
we need someone like you but
not just for what you can bring from a
bd perspective but we need someone who's
going to like shake the tree and
unsettle things because
it was going well but it was contingent
recruitment going well right you know
they had a couple of bigger contracts
but really it was a contingent machine
and it really was a machine
so i just thought look i i've moved
house i've i've left liverpool i've gone
to london i'd put everything on the line
really so
i wasn't gonna just quit again yeah
ain't committed you know i've got yeah
so i thought
um
pardon me i thought [ __ ] it i'm gonna
give it a go and let's see what happens
so i just went on like a three-month
mission that i set myself and at the end
of three months i want to know they had
this brilliant quarterly awards uh
ceremony where like high achievement was
really um acknowledged and i won the
ward as the best newcomer at the end of
it and that was it
people were responding it was still
difficult you know getting them to take
me on meetings getting to log stuff on
the system so that i could see it um
seeing some of the rates that were being
charged and thinking oh my god you know
it's easy it's easy to sell a contract
against this and wipe every other
supplier out because we're charging so
much that you know we can uh we can
undercut ourselves but that's a bold
decision so it was difficult but i was
also starting to get buy-in
um okay and that buy that buying went on
for you know two two or so years then
there was a change at the top md left
and
that was a really critical time for me
um
one md left new md came in
and the mindset i'd always had was the
risk i'd had by going down a bd only
route not running a sales team not being
on a desk not having a bill in line i
was always told i'd never be able to get
to a board seat because you've got to
have a revenue line you've got other
team
knew that new md came in she was from
within the business it was like a step
up so she knew that she and she knew me
and she said to me i can get you to
board without taking a sales team
because i believe in you and
and to be honest it was that it was that
belief in that environment and even that
was you know we had some hurdles to come
across um yeah
things didn't maybe work the way i
thought they should have i've got a bit
of a temperament i threw my toys out the
pram on numerous occasions she was she
was the right foil so i think
the reason i
like talk about that story so long is it
all started there to be able to start
the day yeah yeah yeah
readers where i learned recruitment and
i
you know i knew that i could sell i've
been selling for a long time i've been
selling since i was like 14 so i knew i
could sell um reid taught me that
recruitment and the cell and the cut and
the consulting that goes with it
morgan unleashed like the
the belief that i actually wanted to
make that my career i wanted to climb
the ladder and i wanted to you know to
do it within that sort of environment oh
yeah fair okay so just a quick one
interested
what
what what has been like obviously
because you then obviously so you so it
seems like there's a bit of a struggle
at the start then you got then you
obviously built some trust credibility
like won that award and then obviously
obviously wouldn't have been plain
sailing but you had more buying as you
said then obviously cooper home as you
went in at a senior level then digital
gurus went on a senior level so my
question is
i think sometimes a lot of people listen
to this who are like senior can be quite
worried about going into a recruitment
environment at sort of a leadership
position or in a senior position so
what's your advice for people who
um may want like you said one feel like
they need to be stimulated need a new
challenge yeah but don't want to end up
in an environment where they may end up
being a leader who people don't like or
they don't get i don't know what's your
advice to them yeah people don't go into
new company and just
like a [ __ ] of a leader to put it
another way basically do you know what i
mean the new guy comes in trying to
implement his own way of doing things
but watch because you've done that a few
times now what's the approach yeah
well i mean first of all there's
definitely going to be some people
listening to this thinking buddy is a
[ __ ] leader so i don't know what
it's like to say at this point
and and and i guess maybe you know
that's for everyone else to decide for
me there's nothing worse than a stale
director there's nothing worse than a
stalemate in this industry because you
have to drive your teams so hard every
day and if you're lethargic with it you
know after all of that struggle that we
just i just talked about at morgan hall
i got to the board i got they i got in
the boardroom and fundamentally i was
gone within a year because i was
disillusioned by what the boardroom
represented and i guess
you know
you could argue you need to have a grip
to see that through and and turn it and
shape it but for me you have to have
that belief
but i never wanted to be stale i was
always that director that went the pub
on a friday and i was sort of like
chatting to the teams um into what
people listening to what people were
saying and
for me
i heard i heard how others referred to
other directors and other leaders and
other senior uh management within that
business you know that business had been
phenomenally successful and then that's
one channel buzzing at my door sorry
that that business had been phenomenally
successful
and um
it didn't need near enough doubled in
size so obviously a lot more seniority a
lot more people and what have you so i
never wanted to get stale and then when
i went to
so ultimately you know i i moved i went
for the opportunity to shoot for an mvc
i was i was on the board it was border
six it was a brilliant board at morgan
hunt but i went to cooper lomas because
the opportunity was it was clearly there
for an mv's job very very you know i was
36 at that point making maybe 35 35 36
it was it was arguably too early but the
opportunity was there and i'd always
been ambitious so but even when even
there i never wanted to be stale i
always want to be fresh so my advice is
if anyone sat there you know yourself if
you're going through the motions um yeah
it's hard enough going through the
motions on a desk in this job
but you but you can i think as a
director if you're going through the
motions your team will know that and i
never ever i i guess maybe i care too
much what people thought as well i never
wanted them to call me out as you know
simon's lost his passion and simon's
loss to drive and then if if so
so i guess what would your advice be for
simon that goes you know what i do need
a new challenge i'm going to go to a new
company what would your advice be for me
to make sure that yeah we don't go into
um
don't go into that new environment
trying to like i don't know just because
i'm sure you've got better at this right
where you go into a new company and
you've got approach in a quite tactful
way right you don't want to go in there
and go right everyone i need to do a
whole new way of doing things like what
would your advice be for a leading
transition to a new recruitment business
maybe things to avoid or what would you
say something like maybe don't do this
or do this first or really like double
down on doing this what would your
approach be your advice be well i think
i think do you go in and shake the apple
tree you know when i first
first went to
i went as the commercial director there
was an ops director and it was clear
that we were going to need an md at some
point and it you know that was very much
how it was sold to me the mds the owners
were removed for the business so
effectively
you know we were 52 heads uh 35 of them
also were sales they all sat with me you
know go for it
my my old md had then said to me don't
do anything for 100 days just like sit
and watch and okay and then for 100 days
and you know
really good advice sit there for a
hundred days do three management
meetings do three
uh board meetings see how essentially a
quarter
um yeah yeah yeah
yeah get the load of the land and then
yeah
i lasted three days i didn't make it
three months i didn't make a hundred
times i probably lasted 100 hours i i i
had a there was a management meeting
that was due to shadow with on about day
four or so
and it just wasn't me yeah i did i did i
did and i think that someone once told
me um
someone once said to me when they'd
hired me
well i guess if things were perfect we
wouldn't be hiring and i've always had a
problem with this i've never liked it
this thing they said if things were good
we probably wouldn't have hired you
because we don't need someone you know
you're going to come in and shake it up
and change it and i think that's part of
i think we should move when we're our
best my advice to whether it be someone
who's looking to hire us thinking about
a senior person or whether it be about
senior person looking to move move at
your best because that's when you're
full of confidence that's when you're
full of juice that's when you're full of
let's go so i went into cupolomas and
thought that you know i could take on
the world now arguably
you know maybe that bravado and that
belief system played against me but that
company had been through a challenging
period and it needed someone to grab it
by the scrub for the neck
you've got to take the people with you
there's no doubt about it
but it depends on your personality if
you if you have the patience to sit and
watch for three months i reckon you'd
probably have the longevity to get past
me however
i just was super competitive super
determined and super just keen to get
stuck in i didn't have the patience for
hanging around for 100 years because
there was there was sort of things to
achieve
yeah fair enough but celebration my
advice i guess is go when you go when
you're good and also
be be you be whatever you are yourself
yeah yeah if you're patient be patient
if you're eager to be eager
yeah yeah sure so let's talk about
before we get on to digital 51 then
let's talk about as you've as you saw
framed up quite nicely drawing cooper
lomas and as you said like there was a
real genuine opportunity there to become
the md
yeah and i'm assuming part of the drive
for you was wow this is this is actually
a business that i could end up part
owning or or or having chairs and
etcetera right is that fair
well that's to be fair to the owners
that's why they took me there okay yeah
so they told you that from the very
beginning yeah they came they came for
me twice um
and the first time when i was at
very maybe a couple of years at morgan
hunt and i was really i was that that
leadership change was happening at that
point and you know
i was happy and things were going well
and i wanted to stay but i've been
impressed by the
you know
what they've done with it with the
regional business and also they were
clear they wanted someone to lead an mbo
and the existing leadership team
you know wasn't really set up that way
so when they came back again they came i
was in a different point in my career
and they were at the point where i come
in
you know if
you're if you're good enough you'll be
the md and then the plan is within you
know five years we'll sell the business
to you and and the leadership team and
you'll take it on so to be fair they set
it up in that way
that was actually the intention okay
yeah yeah yeah and that was you know
that was very much again people thought
you know people thought i was nuts that
i left
london to move to east anglia
to run a regional business um
which was you know 50 engineering
manufacturing it wasn't where my
background was
but the opportunity was i mean while it
was a fantastic business in my opinion
and two the opportunity to buy it and
bmd as well yeah it's genuine like they
told you about from day one so
can you could you could you just start
then could you just describe
like she mentioned there so could you
describe for people listening what what
the sort of they were like what the
opportunity was like just break it down
simply so what did they say to them it
was like simon if you sort of basically
do these sort of things well what you'll
be able to do is basically buy us out
and then you and the rest of the
leadership team will be able to carry on
with like what what did the actual
potential actually look like to spell it
out
yeah it didn't really pan out in that
way and to be honest
it we it got
we had to go through a major bump so so
essentially we did
two years um yeah in the by the end of
the first year um i'd be coming i i've
pitched to bmd and i've been awarded
that opportunity and we were reshaping
the business based on that um and then
um at the end of the second year yeah
it was clear financial performance was
good however the underlying value set of
the business had changed you know it'd
been privately owned for so long however
it'd been through you know a series of
md's and and a few shakes and um
shake-ups along the way and some bumps
and for a whole host of reasons all the
things that you see in recruitment
businesses that you know it's a
30-year-old business in the day so my
belief was
right
we haven't really spoke about it from
that from when i first went in you know
it was you know come in
get get settled yeah get it get it
really growing because it started to
stagnate um
two of the the previous leadership team
had set up rival businesses and they
were actually being really successful
and there was a lot of poaching and
stuff going on so setting all that down
and then let's get on a journey and it
was probably about halfway through about
two and a half years and this this is
really what happened so we used to have
a board meeting
and and i and i managed the board
meeting so i managed the agenda and all
that went with it and
and
i've had a feeling for a while that we
couldn't get on the journey to
an mbo without fundamentally changing
the underlying shape of the business
ripping it right down to its value set
re rebranding it redefining the values
and that they had to be mined they
couldn't be a group they couldn't be a
collective they couldn't be me and the
owners going on a journey they had to
really if i was going to drive it to
that point then i had to drive it that
way so many owners right there
there's two there was two
two two owners um as i say
established a fantastic business and to
be fair gave me complete autonomy
stepped away
and what have you and let me run their
business
and then we had board meetings so
um
you know i was probably one of my
proudest moments but also one of my the
most challenging i bought i set a board
meeting i didn't tell them that i was
going to turn up at the board meeting a
proposition to pro to buy the business
to buy it okay yeah so normally the
senior management team everyone they
would all come so i told no one else to
come on that day the two owners and we
had a non-exec director so we sit down
and obviously everyone's like it's
slightly different the agenda i was i
was sort of bluffing a bit over an
agenda and yeah
and everything it's slightly different
anyway we sit down everyone has their
coffee and i'm like right we're not here
for a board meeting
i think we've got to drive to an mbo now
i think we have to start the job this
was 12 months earlier than we'd ever
planned to do it
and i said so i then kicked off the ball
rolling so i said i think we should
start now these are my reasons i
presented that on the day i was like
this is why i think we should start now
and these are the risks i think if we
don't do it but i just don't think we
can wait any longer um the money was
fine it was it was the the problems were
coming
at a
you know a people level and a value
level and for me
those things have become more and more
and more important so i was like i want
to get on this journey i want to make it
you know my belief system my values yeah
yeah yeah okay that's my team and that
will drive us to be the success to get
the numbers that we need to trigger
um
what have you however financially we
were in a different position you know we
the business had had fundamentally
shifted from where it was when i first
started and therefore some of the
numbers that have been spoken about over
time
that that wasn't where we were so i then
offered a new price um which was
declined and all this is in one meeting
with the price
well obviously it's but you know you're
basing it on an ebitda and you're
basically on a multiplier it was
predominantly a perm business
um
and also i didn't want to over leverage
the business i wanted to make sure it
was a number that i believed that i
could raise um yeah yeah how did you get
that information then did you reach out
to your network how did you because this
would have been new to you
well no because i i obviously am the as
you know the md i was running the p l
anyway so
so yeah and and i when i was at morgan
hunt um and i became a director there
you know they're very very bored very
strong board governance
that business talk about journey so i
have that context also just plugged into
the wider recruitment community in terms
of listening to when deals happens and
things like that so essentially and then
also like anything in in life
recruitment's no different everything's
got a price but also everything
it's worth what someone's willing to pay
for it so i fundamentally i offered the
price that was linked to a multiplier
off the ebit but i also offered a price
that was linked to what i thought it was
worth
and and that's what we put down that was
actually declined on the day the whole
thing was declined it was a pretty how
did they take it was it like what the
[ __ ] going on
um
yeah uh yeah
one pissed off one surprised one sort of
shot but also it made sense but to be
honest
this was on um
this was on i think it was a thursday or
friday it was going into the weekend i'd
planned it specifically that way yeah
yeah and then we had a call on a sunday
and they were like yeah we agree let's
do it we'll we'll agreed at the price
yeah yeah yeah we agreed at the price
but what they did say is
this can't affect
so it can't affect the run in the
business and
and
ultimately you've set the price so
you know you have our permission to
engage whoever you need to around equity
you know raising the money et cetera et
cetera
which was good because that allows you
to share the books which is what you
need to do yeah but essentially it's
your party time and you've caused this
go and see
my cabin
see what you can do yeah let's just
let's just talk about this for a second
and then we'll move on so yeah she got
to that kudos to you mate
like put like just putting out there and
like being like as you said like back
yourself
creating opportunities so
so i guess what i just want to just find
out you don't have to give me the
numbers or anything but yeah could you
just spell out for people just make this
really simple for people
what what did that sort of what a high
level what did that deal look like so
putting figures away so let's just say
cos x amount and then what would that
mean would it mean that you would they
would then all sign a contract that said
over three years if this happened simon
would then own the majority share like
what what was like just about left buy
out so
all of their shares
straight buy out yeah so
[Music]
you're talking um
second seven figure plus deal so yeah
we're not talking you know
um pocket change depends how big your
pockets are i guess but i think because
i'd offered a different price than we
originally spoke about because i had
fundamentally offered less than than
they thought value that um that and also
i guess i had done it in a slightly more
hostile way um
yeah
but the deal was gonna bomb completely
out because that is
the conversation i've had sometimes it's
like a over a period of time
it was it was a mistake in to be honest
in hindsight the easiest bit was
um
having the balls the ambition and the
drive to get that meeting and get to
that position what i should have however
the harder bit then was to move it and
get it over the line and what i what i
actually should have done in hindsight
was i should have presented a partial
deal i should have presented x amount um
like seventy thousand
now because fundamentally that's how
that's why it fell through it fell
through
because of my ability to raise the full
hundred percent of the money as needed
and then also run the business at the
same time yeah yeah and juggle those
things and yeah yeah okay so thanks for
sharing that so that makes sense so let
let's just let's just talk about
the finance journey because i think this
is sometimes from the conversations i've
had sometimes people can be i don't know
what people's assumptions are if they're
going yeah my boss had talked to me
about an mbo i don't know what their
assumptions are around finance but i
think sometimes
people can underestimate like how
difficult it may be to raise funds to
make that happen so just just for really
simple terms here like let's just say
you listen to this and
yeah there's a carrot in front of you
right now that you could go on an mbo
journey there is a good chance that for
that to happen you will have to to raise
money because you're they're going to
need x funds and it could be like you
said the partial deal or like you went
down like the complete full whack so in
order to do that you needed to get x to
the table so what
so where where where did you even begin
to look for these funds then did you
like did you go to did you go to bank
straight away did you already like what
was the
the finance plan
yeah so i had three i had three
revenue plans for my my journey to make
this happen so the first thing first is
if you're in if you're in a temp
business or an interim business or a
contract business um
if you
if you don't factor your debt and if you
don't invoice discounts and things
essentially if you manage all of your
own cash flow then then
the business has got a very and the
business has more than likely got a good
financial cash position
so going into this this decision i've
worked with the finance team to really
tighten up our debtor situation so that
our debtor was in a position where it
was x amount and we were comfortable
with that because that that affects
future lending but also at the same time
i tried to drive the temp revenue as
hard as possible because the higher temp
revenue is i was then going to lend
against that so fifty
percent fifty percent of my buyout was
was lending against the existing against
the existence okay yeah which which to
be honest is
is a tried and tested route if you don't
wanna put a large chunk of your own
money yeah
i feel like not not many people will
actually be able to do that like if
because most people i speak to are i
don't know late 20s early 30s uh in
direct positions and i don't know they
might have done all right money wise and
say but really how much how if you're in
the board if you're a director of two
forever people how many of you are going
to have 50 100 grand plus to put into
the deal potentially i don't know do you
know what i mean
yeah so i think that look if you just
take for example
for ease of maths if if your if your
contract book is worth 1.1 million a
year for argument's sake yeah
and you've got like i mean obviously
there'll be lots of specifics to your
own business yeah
but if you've got fundamentally a good
business and you're on top of your
debtors and you've got long-term running
temps contractors interims again
whatever you want to call them and
you're and you've been with your own
bank for a period of time the likelihood
is they'll lend you 90 of that
so
they'll lend you a million quid against
the against the existing temp because
because it's so so
that that bit's actually you know no
you don't doesn't cost you anything to
do that that will cost you interest and
obviously yeah arrangement deals and so
on and so forth but
per it's not that big that fundamentally
cost so you have for me as i say three
revenue streams the first one was the
easiest one was to lend against the
ticket against him that makes sense
that's ten bucks so if you've got
an interim book then that
is
what drives the price of the business
which is why you pay more in the first
place but it also is your biggest asset
if you don't have like lots and lots of
money floating around that you can lend
against it straight away so again if
it's against a straight perm business
you've not got that you haven't got the
temp revenue to lean against but also
your multiplier will be less yeah
because you know
i was running a
contract business where our average
contract tenure was over six months um
so
long standing
um yeah yeah yeah revenue that your bank
can see so first of all so you've got to
do that you can either go you can either
go to your existing bank for that or you
can go to you know a whole host of
people and they'll lend against you so
yeah i i had that conversation and then
it sounds really simplistic and stupid i
went to my actual our bank so every
business has a bank obviously who
they're with so with the agreement again
of the owners i said i need to have a
conversation with our bank i obviously
had a relationship with them anyways you
know as the mba although the f you know
the fd was had run everything but i went
to see them and essentially said
this deal is now on the table
um
i want you to affect i want you to lend
me the other half essentially that's
that's why that's what i went in with
and then at the same time as doing that
i reached out to a broker so like the
most terrifying meeting i ever went to
is i went to a meeting in paternoster
square um real high-end
brokerage uh um
organization that
that specifically looked at mergers and
acquisitions for recruitment businesses
they brought along their lawyers they i
mean i turned up on my own with a
notepad and a pen
and like some scribbles of what i was
doing and i had like my printouts of my
excel sheets and all this i had like my
board pack
and and these like guys would literally
sat around the table but but to be fair
they were brilliant they i got loads of
advice from that and that was my third
revenue choice so yeah
so what would they do they would take
get with it gather all the information
and then look to get lenders buyers
yeah so they would you know they would
give you a whole host of options now i
ultimately decided not to go down that
route because as brilliant as they were
and to be honest i had two sessions with
that group of individuals which taught
me more my my regret was i should have
done that before i even got to the point
where i picked that point yeah the deal
those listen maybe go look at that route
if there's another 100 percent
you've got to be careful in terms of you
know the benefit of doing it the way i
did meant that i had the blessing of the
people who's fundamentally it was you
know even as the md you might think it's
your business it's not it's whoever's
name is officially you know on that door
and they gave me the blessing to share
that information so
um you know you shouldn't you shouldn't
share that information if you've not got
the blessing to do so but i did have
which was the benefit however those two
meetings made me
realize i didn't want to do it in that
way because i
wanted to know and this again in
hindsight was a mistake that i wanted to
know exactly where the money was coming
from and i wasn't really interested in
angel investors and okay and vc and
private equity and all those bits and
pieces was you protective of that what
was you conspired about me
do you know what
probably a bit of inexperience first and
foremost
um
you're a bit worried about taking other
people's money
the unknown yeah and i guess part of my
personal driver was control and
ownership of right
of the situation and what i thought is
if
if i ended up with
um another owner in there who you know
equity or whatever and they own 30 to
get the deal over the line is that today
is that really better than where i am
yeah and again what i should have done
at that point it should have restored my
conversation around you know a stage
buyout so so because i decided not to go
down that route
i
i essentially got 75 percent yeah 75 of
the money agreed in place um yeah you
know from
from like the the the temp book and the
bank yeah
however the bank wouldn't give me the
full amount that i asked for so at that
point you then go to your own personal
resources and you're like right am i
putting my house on the line am i doing
this
and i've made the decision going in that
i was willing are you i think if you're
going for a if you're going for
a multi-million pound deal if you're
going for a deal that's over a million
quid or so you you have to acknowledge
that you're going to need to you're
going to need to have some money um yeah
you're going to have to have some
resources
you're going to have to have resources
in my opinion you're going to need to
have 50 grand ready to go now you don't
because you can leverage it against the
business a bit like when you do a
mortgage you know you can you can just
top all the fees on top of but
you know what i thought was it just
making the situation worse that on
day one when it's all mine if it's
completely riddled with debt
um
well you're under pressure from day one
and the reason i wanted to go down the
route that i was was your guest was a
slight disagreement around how much
profit needed to be made by business and
therefore
that that you know
that was sort of niggling me all the
time that the push for finance is what
in my opinion makes recruitment turn so
many people away because it becomes too
money driven
and that turns people off so i didn't
want to riddle myself however
fundamentally that cost me the deal at
the end because then i you know holding
my hands up i had took my eye off the
ball with the business
[Music]
so the values piece the rebrand then all
of that was going phenomenally well the
team were probably the happiest they'd
been in sort of three and a half years
it was going really well but our our
figures had just started to tank a
little bit i think it was a bit you know
i think that's what sometimes people
people forget though i had to go on here
recently matt who shared his journey and
that was one of his bits of advice is
like one don't like be serious about who
you potentially doing this with as a
leadership team like there's a
difference between you being
leadership like both being leader in the
leadership position and both you being
business partners but to like also yeah
don't underestimate that also you're
gonna have to go on this journey with
them where you're gonna have to put over
100 hours on top of your actual job
outside of work do you know what i mean
so because you're still employed you
still got a number you still got to
drive that performance so i guess to to
tie this together thank you so much for
being super honest on all that so i
guess his final thing and then we'll go
into digital 51 what for people
listening them and i know there's
nuances here but for people listening if
we sat down in the pub and i'm going to
hurt simon
really really interesting story that you
went on didn't quite work out right now
me and my leadership team there's a
couple of us and an mbo's on the table
like that
our owners have said like they want to
carry on the they they want to take a
step back they see us as the future
leaders that's that's a serious offer on
the table like what what advice would
you give those people to go right maybe
think about finding this out from them
this is maybe what i'll do differently
what would you say to those people that
generally have an mbo carrot in front of
them knowing what you know now
i think first things first is you need
to make sure that you need to make sure
it's genuine
do cause sometimes it is a carrot do
they do they really want to sell um
and again you know
i regret where we ended up that i wasn't
able to get that deal over the line
however i think
if
when push came to show at the end if
both parties had wanted it it was clear
that there wasn't there was an
alternative deal available where we
could have just phased at the the final
part over a certain period yeah
therefore
i always was slightly disgruntled
thinking well maybe they didn't really
really want that deal now that turns out
not to be true because they just
completed an nbo two years later so they
clearly did so the first thing first is
make sure this is generalities yeah it
really is genuine and and you know test
that in terms of um
things that i need to look at to start
the process or that yeah yeah the first
thing is you've got to have an open book
yeah
that's what that's that's what the guy
said recently if you don't have the full
corporation it's a non-starter yeah and
i think it also tells you if there's not
that full cooperation open book around
um where we're at what's going on
finances yeah well well
certainly around possibly the money that
they're taking or possibly yeah what you
need to talk to bank i was really lucky
i had that complete transparency so i
think getting that open book
get get some advice you know
whilst those two meetings that i had um
with real professionals taught me a lot
probably one of the reasons i didn't go
with down that route was not just the vc
but it was also the extra fees that were
involved in using these people and in
hindsight
i didn't have the experience to do the
deal you know i didn't have it and
therefore
ultimately that cost me so
although it might not have needed to be
with them there were so many other
people out there who i probably could
have reached out to who could have got
me that support so for me
get gets if you've never done it before
it is
i don't care what anyone tells you
it is every situation is unique and it's
very very stressful it can it sounds
exciting but it you know it gets very
detailed very very quickly you have to
be really good with the numbers um which
i was lucky i was however you know
you've got to live and breathe that all
the time and to be honest a slightly
more wiser head around someone who'd
been through it before would have got me
over the line because my passion drive
determination and risk level was there
but it was just it was just being cute
enough to understand the deal and i
wasn't yeah
now great advice so let's talk about
digital 51 then
yes so talk to me about sia before we
finish here last 10 15 minutes like talk
to me about where
so i think this ties into the to like
what you're about now right so talk to
me just a bit about
why why are you so passionate about
giving this business away in 11 years
and two what does that actually mean and
look like for people listening to
understand a bit about that instead of
it yeah i don't want people think it's
like a nice brand strap line and what
you're about but talk to us about what's
important to you and two how that
actually works how that's going to work
yeah well i think sort of after you know
i went to digital gurus after
where i was and that was a that was a
private equity owned business and
these two things have shaped my mind set
around how how and why you should run a
recruitment business you know
fundamentally i couldn't get the deal
over the line at cooper lomas i've got
to accept responsibility for that
however i i did have niggles that i
thought the deal could have been made
easier and then secondly going to dg
which is a phenomenal business but part
of a bigger group i guess i got to saw
got to see what what what it looks like
when you run a business off a
spreadsheet and that wasn't really my
bag either
so
i decided if i was going to do it myself
then how would i be different than those
two offerings yeah
and
i think i also wanted the hard stop i
want i i want to step out in 10 years
time i want to step out in 10 years time
you know
i i need that hard stop for me that i
can do something else and enjoy all the
things and you know what have you so i
need that hard stop for me
why as we go on that journey we we're
six people now be at seven in a couple
of weeks
whatever that growth looks
like why should those people come here
and run through walls for me if there's
nothing in it for them and yeah i just
think
over time everyone's beliefs and drivers
change and mine has not become about the
bottom line money as much anymore i just
think that
the last 18 months has had that impact
on me around
i just think so many businesses got
screwed and covered because they were
run badly i'm so sorry to say that
we didn't have a long enough we didn't
have a long enough run of our pnls to
cover our own businesses for six seven
eight nine months so everyone [ __ ]
themselves jumped onto furlough got rid
of their teams so on and so forth and
that's because of the financial
financial underpinning there's loads of
broad strokes in there and i'm sure
there's loads of people sat yeah that's
not what happened but you know for me
i just didn't want to like stress that
new business in that way um
so
so therefore if you take
away the fact that i'm going to run it
for 10 years so i can make as much money
as i can to you know
go off to a sailboat in the med and you
take that away and you're not doing it
for that reason then why are you doing
it and for me
i guess i've always
wanted to
to be part of the team and to lead the
team and to have that sort of
shared goal i i guess fundamentally this
is going to sound like a line
fundamentally i believe
that
people are capable of anything however
not everyone knows or believes that so
therefore i want to show anyone who
walks through this door
that they can own this business and they
will own it if as long as they are here
in 10 years time and they've been a part
of that journey and so on and so forth
so i
i
i never had that opportunity
i want to create it for someone now yeah
well um and then how i don't know if you
like this still would be i don't know
like how would that actually work or is
that not decided yet or is it yeah i
think i think we'll start
you know first of all i'd be lying if i
said it's completely down in black and
white exactly yeah but yeah
you've committed and you're oh he's
there
yeah it's like that's it's not me yeah
what i'd like to do is i'd like to be by
the end of um by the end of our second
year sort of really by the end of 2022
i'd like to be five percent
employee-owned already at that point i'd
like to have started the journey to have
started maybe maybe start with an
employee trust for five percent of the
business yeah and and and get on the
journey as quick as you know as quick as
humanly possible yeah um
and then and then also that will
that will well that is that is the plan
the plan is to have five percent
employee owned by the end of the second
year to sort of really prove that we're
serious about it um and then also to
hold me to account to say look if you
can't get to that point in the first two
years then like how on earth are you
going to get there yeah they're
following yeah following yeah okay so
obviously you've started this business
with other people right yep yeah how how
have you have you i'm always interested
in hearing this but like more and more
people i speak to that do have
co-founders like how have you made sure
that you're all on the same page and and
that is that's important to you but it's
important to them like how have you made
sure they're like that you're remaining
aligned because there's what is there
free more free of you there's two of us
there's two of us really that
fundamentally drive the business in
terms of the way it is you know um day
in day out and i guess
the um
you know adrienne who runs the business
alongside me in reality he's
you know
she's younger than me she's better than
me she's more determined than i am so my
plan is that ultimately if i have my way
she'll lead the business moving forward
you know she'll take it on it'll be
it'll be employee-owned with her at the
helm you know that was that was always
the sort of that you know the plan going
into the business was that
um
why we came in collectively as sort of a
as a three there was really a two sort
of pronged attack to go out and that
that plan was that i would take her
on a journey to help her develop and
become a leader of a business and and
learn how to run a business and and and
so on and so forth
and fundamentally she would then take
that business off me and and and you
know take it forward with with the wider
team because yeah
i just think that she is you know she's
phenomenal and therefore we've got we've
got shared belief system on so many
things yeah don't get me wrong
some of our discussions can get heated
because they're temporarily as bad as
mine in fact if she's listening i'd say
a tempo is well worse than mine
however
however
underneath that passion underneath that
you know that angst i also think the
angst is good is a shared belief around
people and growth
yeah doing it doing it i guess like the
businesses you want to work work with
right now you could be working with
anyone can't you know if you can't pick
up jobs now you're never going to pick
up jobs we don't want that we're trying
so hard to stay true to the the client
and candidate base that we want
yeah so look before we finish then what
obviously what
what have you what would you say like i
know we were sitting before like you've
you guys have really worked hard getting
towards the end of the year it's been
obviously it's been great but this same
time like it's been really difficult
what would you say what have you
what have you learned most this year so
far on this journey would you say
about yourself or about yeah yeah i
think
what i've learned is it is it's easier
to start than it is to do um i didn't
at the start you know at the start i
finished with
digital gurus on the last day of um
jan and we opened on the 1st of march
and i haven't we haven't done
tons of stuff to be honest in the
background because of colby and all that
went beforehand so
it was just sort of go go go but in
hindsight it was easy now that we're
going and there is six of us because
again we didn't start as a one or a two
and there's nothing against anyone who's
going down that route you know i'm at a
different point in my life in my career
where i was like if i'm going to go i
need to go in bigger from the start to
giving us the chance so i guess what
i've learned was it was there was
nothing to lose at the beginning it was
all like let's just do it let's just
like yeah like the energy was driving us
that energy
only i i think that my energy can keep
me going forever and in reality it can't
and and and it's we've got a brilliant
year we are two deals away
from hitting our our goal and you know
when this might go out i don't know but
the reality is it's coming towards the
end of october and we're two deals away
from hitting some of the goals that we
set that we didn't want to hit by the
end of december so that's been brilliant
however
we're probably more frazzled than i
think i would like us to be you've still
got balls every day you've still got
that balls at this yeah doing it in the
right way we're doing it differently
however i think the last six weeks it's
become more about the doing than it has
the greatest
and i think
it's quite hard to accept that when
you've had that as such a strong driver
at the beginning so for me it was all
about doing it differently and the
values and you know
and in the last six weeks we've probably
just been doing the deals and doing the
you know
work job sometimes you've got to check
yourself back on that avenue because
that's what really gets you going isn't
it is the what like reminding yourselves
why you're doing it and
as you said when you're
doing it you can sometimes forget that
because you've got the
the challenges directly in front of you
that you've got front of mind you've got
the deals that should be happening right
in front of mind and yeah i get that
that makes sense and don't get me wrong
anyone who's doing it right now is you
know
this is a this is the this is brilliant
this is like the best i've seen in 15
years it's absolutely phenomenal but
it's hard it's hard you know which is
really really hard yeah it's got
different challenges than that but yeah
yeah and it's and it's relentless it
never ever
it never ever turns off and i think
you've got to
i am awful at it i listen to people on
your on this all the time talk about
their ability to turn off and i'm like
yeah it's harder than that
yeah so i think what i've learned is
that now
um we need to take a bit of it we need
to take a break um we need to have a bit
of a risk we need to have a reset and
there's also nothing wrong with biting
down on the gum shield and doing what
you need to get done at the time you
need to get it done to move to the next
stage yeah i just think i just think
that you can't bite down on that gum
shield for too long for too long yeah
yeah
otherwise you know the strength
sustainable takes over yeah it's not
just it's not and and like
it you know the adrenaline and the
driving whatever it can only drive you
so much because obviously everyone's got
their own stresses outside of work and
all that good yeah
you know it sort of gets on top of you
look simon that's uh that's the pod mate
thank you uh thanks so much for being
thanks so much for being super honest
i wish i knew i knew you would be but i
know that helped a lot of people
particularly around the nbo getting your
promotions i think kudos to you mate on
like clearly you can tell that you've
really backed yourself in your career um
and i think i'm really excited to see
where you guys in the next couple of
years will absolutely get get you back
on the pod in the next few years mate
and see where digital 51's at but
honestly thank you so much for coming on
really enjoyed it
yeah enjoy